بعد ليله عنيفه هنا في شمال القطاع
وبالتحديد في جباليا البلد ومخيم جباليا
تمكنا من الوصول لهذه المنطقه في هذا
الصباح منطقه الجرن قام الاحتلال بتدمير
عدد كبير من المنازل وايضا المساجد كما
نشاهد ايضا هناك عدد من
الشهداء لم تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه من
الوصول اليهم في هذه المنطقه لخطوره الامر
هنا هذه منطقه الجرن في
جباليا الشهداء في داخل المنازل جراء
القصف المدفعي المتواصل على هذه المنطقه
عدد من الشهداء هنا خم اربعه اي هي الابو
وهي البنت
الصغيره نايمين ما شفنا الا الخبط فوقنا
صلاه الط قمنا قمنا لقينا الركام عليهم
واحنا هنا ما عرفناش ايش لا شفنا فضه ولا
شفنا نور راحوا يقوموا عنهم ما لقوهم
كم واحد استشهد استشهد الله يرحم اربعه
ابو العال الخامس في احال ال خطيره ومرته
وبنات اثنتين لم تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه من
محاوله الوصول لهؤلاء الشهداء ما زالوا
هنا داخل هذا المنزل هنا اطفال اطلع
معو حجم الدمار كبير جدا في هذه المنطقه
نستف ما نراه ايضا الاصوات هنا ما زالت
مدفعيه الاحتلال تطلق القذائف في كل
مكان طريق
مسكره نشاهد هنا حجم هذا الدمار بسبب
القصف المتواصل هنا في هذه
المنطقه طبعا هذه منطقه الجرن في جبال
الاحتلال قام الليله بتنفيذ عدد كبير من
الغارات هنا في هذه المنطقه في 25 نفر هنا
اهلي وجرنا كمان بيجوا في 20 نفر كلهم تحت
القاب مش قادرين يطوله مش قادرين يطولوا
حدا منهم طبوا عليهم الساعه خ وصب قفوهم
وقصفوا في المنطقه طبوا فينا بالمدفعيه كل
اهلي ماتوا ما حدش ظل منهم الا انا
واخواتي ثلاثه ابوي وامي واخواتي كلهم تحت
الارض ولاد صغار هنا ست اولاد صغار وفو
كمان في ست اولاد صغار وامهم عايشين
والزلمه ولاده كمان ثلا نفر 50 نفر هنا
طالوا لسه م تحت الارض مش عارف احكي شيء
طبعا ما زالت مدفعيه الاحتلال تطلق
القذائف في هذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه مع
معان يلا يلا عبد الله معان لحظ
شوي هنا هنا احد الاطفال تحت الركام لم
يتمكن احد من الاهالي او من الطواقم
الطبيه انتشال هذا الطفل وهو عباره عن
اشلاء هنا في هذه المنطقه عباره اشلاء
الساعه اعه الصبح فاجانا انه ضرب بدون
سابق انذار ونحنا نايمين نزلن علينا
البيوت ه دار جيراننا من دار المجدلاوي
خمس طوابق كلها نزلت عليهم للحين الناس
تحت الردم مش قادرين نعمل شيء دار حسين
جوا و دار حسين وفي دار الكرد باقوا
نايمين عند بنتهم برضه نفس الشيء انا بيدي
طلعنا خمسه هذه منطقه الجرن اننا ثلاث
ايام الشارع الرئيسي مغلق مش قادرين نتحرك
ولا نطلع ولا ننزل لا اسعافات ولا اي حاجه
ضربوا مدخل الطريق من ه ومن ه الناس يها
تحت الرد مش قادرين نعمل شي الاسعافات
فتحنا الطريق عشان نقدر نطلع الناس
المتصاب يعني الوضع عنا مش طبيعي من
الساعه اعه الصبح لحين وهم ضربوا طيران
وزنان
وكله الان يتم انتشال اصابه من
المكان اطلع
اطلع احتلال هنا شن سلسله غارات على هذه
المنطقه عشرات المنازل دمرت بالكامل ايضا
وجود عدد كبير من الشهداء هذه المنازل
ماهوله بالسكان في هذه المنطقه وايضا
المنازل متلاصقه ببعضها البعض هنا في
منطقه الجرن في
جباليا شاهد هنا يوجد عدد كبير من الشهداء
في هذا المكان وتحت ركام هذا المنزل لم
يتمكن احد من انقاذهم او محاوله انتشالهم
لا يتوفر اي طواقم طبيه او اسعافات او اي
طواقم للدفاع
المدني الان مدفعيه الاحتلال تطلق القذائف
على هذه المنطقه ونحن نتواجد
فيها عبيد
عبيد الان كما
نسمع الان قوات الاحتلال تقوم بالقاء عدد
من قذائف المدفعيه في هذا المكان ونحن
نتواجد فيه هناك عدد من الاصابات في
المكان انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه